major breaking news a Donald Trump might
not be the dumbest Donald Trump it might
be Donald Trump jr. who gets the award
for dumb dumbest Donald Trump Donald
Trump jr. admitted in a completely
softball interview on Fox News with sean
hannity yesterday that he quote probably
met with other people from russia to
talk about influencing the presidential
election which is only raising even more
questions and concerns about collusion
with russia
and about his father the current
President of the United States so there
was this disastrous incident that lasted
about 72 hours where Donald Trump jr.
went from having denied any meetings
ever with Russians of with regard to the
campaign to admitting he met with a
Russian lawyer but only to talk about
Russian adoption to admitting he met
with a Russian lawyer under the pretext
of getting dirt about Hillary Clinton
but alleging he never actually received
that information to then releasing
emails which only further incriminating
incriminated him proving beyond any
doubt that he was completely unsurprised
by Russia favoring his father and
working to help his father in this
election so in an attempt to kind of
ease concerns about this meeting with
the Russian lawyer on behalf of the
Trump campaign he went on the Sean
Hannity program last night and he
admitted that he probably had many
meetings with Russians and Sean Hannity
has been known as if you need to have
someone help you apologize for Donald
Trump or Trump campaign actions you go
to Sean Hannity because you will get the
epitome of the softball interview and
Sean Hannity asked Trump jr. have you
met with other people from Russia and
I'm going to play for you his answer and
it is just it it's a pathetic and
embarrassing gong show that is going on
here
did you ever meet with any other person
from Russia that you know you know I
don't even know I've probably met with
other people from Russia I mean really
not and not in the context of actual a
formalized meeting or anything like that
because it why would I you know in the
grand scheme of things how busy we were
it was much more important to doing this
this was a courtesy to an acquaintance
if he is as
as he claims or was as busy as he claims
why did he meet with both this Russian
lawyer and has he says he probably did
also meet with other people now you
might see just this clip pat and say oh
no big deal he's saying you know I might
have incidentally met Russians but not
as part of the campaign these people are
such liars that any admission at all
even a potential admission needs to be
explored in detail but he says they
weren't formalized meetings he says I
probably did meet with people what he
means is let me translate for you
Patrick
I probably met with other Russians but
I'm not going to admit it until it's
reported by the New York Times or
Washington Post and at that point I'll
try to lie until it's completely
undeniable then I'll admit it but try to
write it off as something we should be
concerned about that's really what he
means by I probably did meet with other
Russians and Donald Trump jr. is also
saying that this was before the Russia
hysteria in Ohio or yeah but this was
perhaps the genesis of the Russia
hysteria and the other thing he's trying
to do is plead ignorance you know we
weren't seasoned campaign official right
we didn't know we were really doing
anything wrong Paul Manafort was in the
meetings who is more seasoned than he is
right I mean it's like it that that
explanation is so bogus and remember he
lied multiple times about the Russian
lawyer meeting until he could lie no
more and now the story has reversed
course 180 degrees Sean Hannity gave
Donald Trump jr. the most soft of
softball questions in this interview and
he still managed to Rio to to sort of
lay the groundwork for even more
explosive revelations he managed to dig
an even deeper hole during a week Sean
Hannity Fox News interview that takes
some talent and apparently Donald Trump
senior was so thrilled with juniors
performance that he jumped back on
Twitter after a long silence about this
saying quote my son Donald did a good
job last night he was open transparent
and innocent this is the greatest witch
hunt in political history sad Donald
Trump jr. is awaiting further reporting
before he's willing to admit
two more wrongdoing he doesn't want to
get ahead of the news reports Pat and
admit to wrongdoing before it's been
reported this is why diversity of media
voices is so acutely important right now
most of what we've altum Utley learned
about the now undeniable unrep Rocha
bULOG zisman sub collusion between the
Trump campaign and Russia has come from
media reporting and investigative
reporting and you need to be prepared
that the drip drip drip could become a
deluge any moment now and sometimes you
have people like Don Jr corroborating
the story that the media is reporting to
and how can we possibly believe him at
this point when he's changed his story
so many different times that he said
that he never had any meetings with
Russians yeah it's the reality and the
original statement are it's almost like
they took place in parallel but
different universes they're so different
and also his explanation that all of
this stuff happened before Russia became
a media frenzy
obviously the transgressions have to
take place before the media reports on
them like how could the media be
reporting about the Russian scandal
before there were any meetings with
Russia like the the meetings are what
caused the scandal it's like he doesn't
understand the forward progress of time
when you have that and incompetence as
your defense it's not going to be very
good for you in front of Congress and in
front of the court it's not going to end
well now everybody wants to talk to Don
jr. Robert Moeller's investigation is
taking interest
you've got the various panels the Hat
the Senate panel that wants to talk to
Don jr. and it is not looking good